does being a vc
make you a better entrepreneur so i got
a great question from one of my youtube
viewers
uh kevin love you guys and he wrote in
to say
would you say getting into a vc would
help you gain skills that would make you
a better business owner
and or angel investor so vc here is
venture capitalist
and i would respond to that absolutely
so when i
when i sold my software company i didn't
know what i was going to do next i wish
i could see i had this clear plan here's
my next steps here's where i'm going
i had no idea and i was i was
frustrated and scared i was kind of
looking for my next
passion project to jump into and i think
we all go through these periods in our
lives where we're not sure what we want
to do next right
and the way to get through that isn't to
force
ideas on yourself and force projects on
yourself but to explore
see what things are interesting for you
and just start to explore and see if
you'd like it or not so i tried a whole
bunch of stuff i tried
rock climbing i tried salsa dancing i
tried getting to venture capital firm
just to see you know not having
expectations just to see what i liked
the reason for getting into venture
capital was with my business
we never needed venture capital we came
close
uh we thought about it we had potential
opportunities but we never actually got
funding for a business our business got
acquired before we went for funding
so it was always one of those things
that i was kind of interested in to see
what it was like
and because i didn't have a business
idea for what to do next i thought
maybe i'll just learn about the vc world
and raising capital and see what it's
like and see if i enjoy it
it could have been something that i
tried for a week and hated it i was
fortunate enough to hook up with
a company in toronto where the main
partners were in their 60s or 70s they
had a whole ton of experience
and they needed help bringing in new
people new businesses
if they could get the businesses they
knew where to go for the funding
so my role is to come in and help them
find new businesses i had friends who
were growing their companies
who needed advice who needed expansion
capital so it seemed like a good fit
and along the way
i learned not just about how to raise
capital
which was great right you see
entrepreneurs come in and they're
getting
asked questions by the main partners at
my firm
and you know i didn't know the answers
to those questions so i had to think
about it too i thought
well for my next venture of irony
capital now i have it all figured out
and it was also great to see how these
businesses
presented themselves how they grew to
where they were
right so part of my job was screening
business plans
and like 99.5
of the plans that came in got rejected
and so i got this
to learn quickly what the difference was
between a great plan and all the others
so i knew if i was writing a business
plan how to make it great
when they came in and they they
presented i got to see how they
presented i got to see what their story
was i got to see who was on their team
how they built their companies
and all that was being soaked up
so i knew if i launched a new company i
could take all that knowledge with me
i got to see how companies grew so
quickly
and what made them so successful and i
gained great contacts through it as well
and again i could use all that i didn't
know
there was no great plan but i was just
learning i was enjoying the learning
process
i was there for maybe two years just
under two years
and through that process i started
working on my own
website and didn't know if it would be a
business or what would happen but it
just started to take off
and i felt like i had learned what i
needed to learn
from the venture capital business and
decided i'm going to leave that
i'm going to do my own thing off of
every carmichael.com in that group
you'll find with things in your life
that
some things you'll love for a little bit
some things you'll love for a long time
and that's okay
you know the vc world i loved for a
little bit and then my passion
fell i felt like i had learned what i
needed to learn and i wasn't excited by
it anymore
that's the time to leave and go do
something else where too many people
feel like oh well getting these skills
i'm really good at this so even though
i'm not that interested in it
i'm gonna keep going because it's a good
career path for me or i can make a lot
of money doing it
if you're not excited by it anymore you
have to move on and do something else
and entrepreneurship was really what was
exciting me and my website
and helping other business owners really
excited me and still does today it's i
still
love it today it's been 12 years i don't
know how long it's been i still love it
it's still great for me if i ever lose
my interest for helping entrepreneurs
then i'll go do something else
but you always have to follow your
passion that's what got me into the vc
world
it definitely made me a better
entrepreneur it definitely made me a
better
angel investor but again you know go
into it
if you're feeling like you love it and
you feel like you want to learn about it
and the moment that that passion stops
then go find something else and it's
okay not to know where you're gonna go
but you know that you're on the path and
if you continue searching you're going
to find something you love
and can hopefully build a massively
successful
and rewarding and fulfilling business
around believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below you
have a question or comment leave it
below and i can make a video response
for you
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you guys for watching so
much
and i'll see you soon